Harding: I'm John Harding.
I'm the engineering manager
for our syndication team,
which kind of encompasses
all of our efforts to--
to bring the YouTube experience
off the YouTube Web site,
and a key part of that,
as we've been talking about,
is--is our APIs.
So...
[clears throat]
kind of give you--what the--
what the big idea that
we're trying to get to today
is that you can take
all the functionality
that people have and love
and use on YouTube
and bring that
onto your site.
And so what that means is,
obviously, people are used
to watching videos.
And you're used to being able
to let people
watch videos on your site
with the embedded player.
But now the APIs
allow you to do things
like search YouTube
for new videos,
find more relevant content
through related,
um, let users
manage their own content--
their favorites,
their playlists,
their subscriptions--
and then,
as Hunter mentioned,
a key aspect of what
we've been enabled recently
is the ability to let your users
upload videos to YouTube
through your own Web site,
instead of sending them to us.
How many people have used
Google Data APIs before?
So pretty good--
about half the audience.
That's fantastic.
For those of you
that haven't,
I'm gonna do a very brief review
of Google Data APIs,
but if you do have
more questions,
I-I definitely recommend you
stop by the office-hours lounge,
and we can kind of walk you
through some of them.
And then I'll go over sort of
the--the common technology
we have
within the YouTube API.
And then we'll actually dive in
and start talking
about what specific APIs we have
and what they enable you to do.
[clears throat]
So all
of our Google Data APIs--
they--they share
a-a common protocol.
They're all based off
of the Atom Publishing Protocol,
and they're RESTful APIs.
So all of our data
typically is represented.
You can get a--different
representations
depending on what
you like to work with.
We do both Atom and RSS feeds,
which are XML-based,
as well as JSON.
And one
of the nice things is,
they use standard HTTP
to do all the requests,
which means that it works well
with proxies.
You've a got
a wide array of--
of network stacks
that you can work with,
and it just uses
the different HTTP methods
to perform di--
different operations.
So, if you want to create,
retrieve, update, or delete,
those all have
corresponding HTTP methods.
We also,
within the Google Data APIs,
have a series
of client libraries
written
in different languages--
Python, PHP,
Java, and .NET
for the YouTube APIs
right now.
And these make it
a little bit easier.
You don't actually have to worry
about XML and the Wire Protocol.
You can deal with objects
in your native language.
So, within the YouTube APIs,
we have a-a couple
of different types of feeds
that we deal with.
The most common one
is the video feed, obviously,
'cause the--the primary content
on YouTube is video.
But we also have a couple
other different data types
that we deal with.
Users can have
subscriptions.
So that's
one type of data.
Playlists as well,
and then contacts,
comments, and user profiles.
In most cases, you know,
even subscriptions
and playlists,
it's pretty straightforward.
But things like profiles
are a little bit different
type of data,
so we'll talk
about that later.
One of the things
I want to stress is that,
you know, most of--YouTube
is about public sharing,
and so most
of the information
that people have on YouTube
is public,
so things like
what videos they've uploaded,
what videos they've "favorited."
And so most of this--
you can get it through the APIs
without any kind
of authentication or log-in.
Some of this information--people
may choose to make it private.
So videos may be private.
Playlists may be private,
for example.
And in that case, you would
require authentication.
But on top of that,
anytime you're gonna modify
any data on the site,
whether that's user data
or whether that's public data,
you'll have to do
authentication,
and we'll talk
about the different ways
that you can deal with log-in
and authentication later on.
So what are these
different types of feeds?
As I said, the most common one
is gonna be a video feed,
and this is basically
just a series of videos.
You can think of it as,
"What data would I need to--
to show that set
of search results on the right?"
And so these use--
these are used
by the vast majority
of our APIs.
So, obviously, you know,
search results, related videos--
what we call our standard feeds,
which are sort of the--
the sets of popular content.
Obviously,
those are all lists of videos,
and so we have a video feed,
but also some
of the more customized data--
user favorites, uploads,
what they've put
into a playlist--
all of these are--
are the exact same type of data.
And so, whether you're doing
search results or favorites,
different use cases,
same structure of data.
So I'm trying to--to do a mix
of different examples here.
So I have some XML,
for people who like going
all the way down to the wire.
I also have some examples
in a couple
of our client libraries.
So we'll try to mix up
so everybody gets a little bit
of what they like.
What I just want to do
is highlight,
you know,
what the actual feeds,
the content that we serve--
from our servers look like.
And this gives you an idea
both of, um...
what information we have
and how it's structured.
But this is also really useful
when you're debugging.
You can actually load up any
of our feeds in the browser
and just examine the XML,
and so it helps you
when you're debugging.
So it's useful to see
what it looks like.
So, up top, you know,
this is a standard Atom feed.
It's XML.
We use the Atom name space.
All of that's
pretty straightforward.
What we have sprinkled liberally
throughout all of our feeds
are related links.
And so this provides
a way for you to navigate
from one API call to another
or from one feed to another.
You can just generate the URLs
on your own,
but it's often useful to be able
to just extract the links
and navigate that way.
In some cases, it's extremely
important to do this,
and the one
that I've highlighted here
is a related link
for the next set
of search results.
So, if you're retrieving
search results
and you want to page through
a lot of content,
the way our search index works
is results are--
the total number of results
is approximate.
And so we may tell you
there's some number of results,
but it's not necessarily
gonna be exact.
And so it's important
to use the "next" and "previous"
links for pagination
to--to kind of sequence
through those.
Speaking of total results,
we use the open search
name space
for telling you where you are
within those results.
And again, that total number,
typically, is an approximation.
Beyond that,
then you start getting
into what information we provide
with each video in the feed.
And so, obviously, you've got
some straightforward things.
You've got title.
You've got the--the uploader.
But what actually
gets pretty interesting
is when you start digging
into the entry itself.
So we have a couple different
categories that we use to--
to sort of label content
within YouTube.
There's three
that apply to videos.
I'm gonna talk
about two of them right now.
So one is keywords.
This is when you upload a video,
you can specify
a couple different keywords
for the video.
We provide those
with the keywords scheme.
And then the actual category
that this video
has been assigned to,
so comedy or sports
or politics.
As I mentioned,
we get the title.
You get the description--kind of
the basic stuff you'd expect.
And then we have more
of these related links.
So, in this case,
this is the--the YouTube
watch page for the video,
if you want to be able to--
to navigate them to YouTube,
as well as, you know,
related video about--
or related data
about the video,
so if you want to see what
responses we have for the video
or get other
related videos to it.
But what you're probably
interested in is,
"How do I actually play
this video back?"
Maybe you could direct them
to our site,
but you can also look
into media RSS extensions
to see, "How do I get
the embeddable player
for this video?"
And so you can see here,
we've got a link to the Swiff.
We tell you
what the duration is,
and then we actually provide
a couple different formats
of many of our videos.
So format 5
is the embeddable Flash player.
So you can tell--either look at
the format to see that it's 5,
or you look
at the MIME type
and see
that it's a Flash content.
We also provide mobile streams
for our videos.
And then, as I said, the--
that media player
will be the link
back to our watch page.
We also give you access
to the thumbnails for the video.
So, on the site,
we--we show one video,
typically,
for a thumbnail.
But if you've
uploaded videos,
you see that we actually
generate three,
and we allow the user
to choose between those.
I've only shown you one here.
We actually provide you links
to all the thumbnails
within the feed responses.
And we also have
a higher-quality version
of some thumbnails available,
which is why we tell you
the time and then the size.
And then we also give you
the statistics
that you'd expect to get--
the view count, the rating,
how many times
it's been "favorited."
One of the things
I also want to highlight is--
there are two different ways
that we provide links
to related feeds.
So we've seen
the standard Atom link element,
but we also have a Google Data
extension called FeedLink.
And what this allows us to do
is give you a hint
about what you can expect
will be in that feed.
So that may be either
account hint, like you see here,
so you don't have to retrieve
that whole feed
just to get an idea
of how much content is there.
But it also allows us
to inline insert a couple
elements from that feed.
So maybe you can show
the first couple comments
without having to fetch
the entire feed.
All right, so that's enough XML
for a while.
If--for those of you
who don't speak in XML,
the plain English version
is basically--
everything you see up here
is what we provide.
You can think about it,
as I said,
anything you need to show
that set of search results
or render your own UI
with all the description
and data about a video.
One thing I want to mention--
as we're going, feel free
to kind of raise your hand
if you've got questions.
We can kind of address those
as we go,
instead of saving them up.
Yeah.
man: When you said--
when you fetch a set of data,
is the entire interface you see
usually available
specifically
for rating the video?
Harding: I'm not sure
I quite follow.
man: So, if you have a rating
of, say, one in five stars.
Harding: Right.
man: Can you import
that interface
to your local instance?
Your local representation
of it on your site?
Harding: Yeah, I mean, you--
you can show that you--
and in fact, we give you--
let's see
if I can pull this back up.
Within the rating tag here,
like--
woman: Can you repeat
the question?
Harding: Oh, the question was,
"Do we give you enough data
"to sort of present the same UI
that we have on YouTube
for something like rating?"
In fact, we actually give you--
I mean, pretty--pretty
fine-grained detail
about--about that.
man: Okay, great.
Harding: All right.
So some of the other APIs
that we have that deal
with video content--
search is, obviously,
a-a pretty popular thing
that you'll want
to be able to do.
So how does search work?
There's an API entry point
to--to issue a search.
And we have a-a pretty broad
array of query parameters
that you can use.
I've highlighted
a couple common ones here.
Obviously, you want
to be able to specify
what search terms
you're interested in.
So there's a parameter
to specify that.
But we give you
a couple different ways
that you can rank
your results.
So you can do relevance,
which is sort of our--
our Google ranking of the video,
publish date, so if you want
to focus on recent videos,
view count
and rating as well.
And when we--when we updated
our APIs in March,
we also started
internationalizing
the APIs as well.
And so, if you have users
that are
in a specific country,
you can actually say,
"Give me results
that are tailored
to that country by relevance."
We also allow you
to restrict results to--
to content
in a specific language.
One thing I want to point is
that right now that restriction
is based off of the text
associated with the video,
rather than the spoken word.
And then finally
we have format restricts.
So I mentioned that we provide
a couple different formats
of videos.
And we allow you to say,
"I want to only get results
that are available
in a given format."
So, if you want to say,
"Only show me videos
that I can embed off-site,"
you can specify format 5,
which is our embeddable format,
and that'll make sure
that you only get videos
that can be embedded.
Users are allowed to--
when they upload a video,
some users say, "I only want
this to show up on YouTube."
So we--basically,
we allow you
to either filter those
out of the search results,
or you can tell by looking
at the response
if we--we gave you
that embeddable player or not.
So a couple examples--
the first thing
everybody always wants to do
is search for Lolcats.
So, if that's
what you're after,
that first one
is--is all you need.
But I got
a couple other examples there.
And then we actually
have a great demo on--
on code.google.com
that I wanted to bring up,
which kind of is a--
where did this go?
Here we go.
So, if you go to our code site
and look for documentation,
there's kind of an interactive
demo that lets you experiment--
see all the different parameters
that you can specify.
So, if I go back--
Sorry, I can't really read
on that--that tiny monitor.
But say I wanted to search
for Lolcats.
We get a great error response,
which is what we were after.
So the d--the dangers
of live demo.
But this kind of lets you
experiment and play around
with the different parameters
that we have.
All right.
So I promised I wouldn't do
any more XML for a while,
so I wanted to go
through an example
using our
Python client library
of how you would actually do
a search.
So all
of our client libraries,
you actually create
a service object,
which is how
you access the APIs,
so that's pretty boilerplate.
And then say we wanted to do
a search for "byobw."
This was the San Francisco
Bring Your Own Big Wheel Race
from a little while ago.
And I want to get
the--the popular ones.
I want to see
what was most viewed.
So I set up my query object.
Run that query
on the service,
and I'm gonna get back
one of those video feeds.
And so--you know, depending
on what you want to do for a UI.
In this case,
I'm just gonna grab
the first thumbnail
out of each entry
and the title
and show that to you.
If we wanted to see
what that would look like,
that is gonna be
this guy here.
So this is the--
the set of search results
for that
Bring Your Own Big Wheel Race.
As I said,
all that information
that you need to render
your UI is there.
This was just a simplified UI
to make the code easy.
But you can provide
an embeddable player.
You can provide links, rating,
whatever you want to do.
All right.
So another common operation
is accessing our standard feeds.
As I said, this is the--
the lists of popular content
on YouTube.
You can think about it
as the equivalent
of the videos tab that we had.
So each of our standard feeds
has a name,
and they're accessed by name.
So some common examples is,
you know,
if you want featured videos,
if you want to see
what are the most viewed
or the top-rated videos.
What's interesting is we provide
a lot of different ways
that you can actually slice
that data.
So most of these feeds
allow you to slice by time,
so whether that's today,
this week, this month.
And one thing
I-I always mention,
just 'cause it tends to confuse
people a little bit,
is those time slices mean
when the video was uploaded.
And so, if you're saying,
"What's top-rated?"
it doesn't mean what got
the most ratings today.
It means what
are the highest-rated videos
that were uploaded today
or uploaded this week.
But we also allow you to break
all these down by region.
So, for all the countries
that YouTube supports,
we have a separate list
of, you know, what
was most discussed in France,
what was top-rated
in Germany.
And then they're also
broken down by categories.
You can say, "Well, within
sports or within politics."
And so you can mix and match
all those different parameters,
whether it's time,
the feed type,
the region,
or the category.
So, for those of you that
speak PHP instead of Python,
again, this
is sort of the equivalent.
You got to instantiate
the service.
Accessing standard feeds
is a little bit simpler.
They each have
their own identifier.
You retrieve that feed.
Then here, this is just
for compactness,
just printing out the title.
So you can see, when you use
the client libraries,
the code to access
the service is very simple,
and you don't actually have
to worry about XML parsing
or protocol management.
The other common video feed
I wanted to talk about
was related videos.
So basically, you know,
corresponding to that little
module on the page there.
Again, these are--
are quite simple,
and so the code samples get
kind of shorter and shorter,
'cause there's really not
that much to show.
You're just gonna get a series
of related videos.
Just tell us what video you want
as the source of related,
and we'll give you back
that set of results.
So I kind of want to do
a quick demo.
We've got, uh...
This is a simple app-engine site
that we've put together.
If you wanted to check it out,
it's ytapidemo.appspot.
So, in this case, I wanted to do
a little bit different UI
for displaying results.
I want to show
all three thumbnails,
'cause maybe I think
that gives you a better--
better handle
on what the content is there.
And so let's say I wanted
to search for Google I/O
to see some talks
from Google I/O,
or let's say,
as always, Lolcats.
And so, you know, basically the
code for this is pretty simple.
In this case, it's--
I have some hand-coded stuff
instead of using
the client libraries.
But also what I wanted to show
is that you can kind of use this
to combine content
in your own way.
So, in this case,
for the home page,
maybe I wanted to show a couple
default video selections.
I've grabbed
just one video each
from most viewed, top-rated,
and featured content,
and so that way,
when people come to the site,
they get a little bit of content
before they start searching
or looking
for their own content.
So, with all of that,
that's, you know,
that's not customized,
that's not personalized.
When people do a search, they're
gonna get the same results.
When people look at related
or those standard feeds,
they get the same results.
And one of the things
that we've learned
about the YouTube experience
is that personalization
is core
to the YouTube experience.
It's all about getting content
that I want to see
or managing,
you know, my videos
or sharing videos
with my friends.
And so we have
a couple different ways
that we allow people
to personalize
their YouTube experience.
You know, some of these you may
have used on YouTube yourself,
some of them you may not.
Subscriptions
allow you to be notified
when new videos
are available,
either from certain users
or matching certain queries.
You can use playlists
and favorites
to manage content that you like
or that you're interested in.
Obviously, you can point people
at your own uploads
to share your videos
with them.
And also people
can manage their contacts--
the people
that they want to share
and receive videos from
on the site.
So subscriptions--there's
a couple different things
that you can do
with subscriptions on the site.
You can subscribe
to a user's channel,
such as lonelygirl15,
if you want to see
the new videos there.
But you can also subscribe
to a user's favorites,
and you can subscribe
to a search query.
We recently added the ability
to subscribe to a user's
playlist on the site,
and that's still to be
implemented within the API.
And so, when you're looking
at a user's subscriptions,
you want to know what kind
of a subscription it is.
And so we actually tell you,
is this a subscription
to a user's channel
or is it a subscription
to favorites or a query.
And depending on the type
of subscription,
there's extra data.
So you can say, "Well,
if it's a channel subscription,
"who did I subscribe to?
"If it's a search-query
subscription,
what was that query?"
And that allows you
to do your own UI
for displaying
the subscription itself
without having
to try to parse out,
you know, the title of the--
the subscription.
Like, if you look on--
on our UI for the site,
you know, if it's a user,
we just show the user name.
If it's a search query,
like cookies,
we put it in--in quotes.
So it's just useful to be able
to differentiate
between those two.
So back to--to XML.
So we use category schemes again
for subscription types
to tell you what it is.
So, in this case, this first one
is a channel subscription,
and that's why
there's a user name
that tells me what the target
of the subscription is,
as well as the link
to the content.
Again, we use those FeedLinks
so that you get an idea
of how much content
is available in that feed
without having to fetch it
up front.
Alternately, I may have had
a-a search-query subscription,
in which case
there's a query string,
instead of a-a user name.
So playlists--a user may have
multiple playlists
that they manage
on the site.
You can see
in this screen shot here,
I've got a couple different
playlists that I--
that I have.
And when you're iterating
over users' playlists,
there's a couple of different
pieces of information
that you'll get
about the playlist as a whole.
So every playlist has title,
description, and tags.
But then also just a pointer to
the contents of that playlist.
The--the contents
of that playlist
are basically the same
as all of our other video feeds.
The only thing
that's different
about a playlist
is that it's ordered,
'cause the user can manage
the order of elements
within a playlist.
And so we also tell you
for each entry in a playlist
what the position is.
It's not as useful
when you're fetching it,
'cause you're probably getting
it in the default order anyway,
but if you want
to allow users
to manage their own playlists
on your site,
you'd want to be able to reorder
the position of elements.
Other customizable feeds--
we have favorites
and user uploads.
So, if I "favorited" videos
on the site,
a lot of people use this
to keep track of content
that they're interested in,
but also, increasingly,
as we added
those subscription features,
people are using favorites
to keep track of content
that they want to share
with everybody else.
So, instead
of explicitly saying,
"I want to send this video
to Stephan,"
or, "I want to send that video
to Hunter,"
I can just favorite it
and know that they're gonna look
at my favorites
and see new videos
as I add them.
This has been actually
a popular feature
that some API clients
have added,
such as Facebook or FriendFeed,
to be able to see what users
have been doing on YouTube.
So favorites is basically
a default, vanilla video feed,
just a set of videos
that the user
has marked as favorites.
When you're looking
at users' upload feeds,
it--it depends
a little bit--
the behavior varies,
depending on whether
the user's logged in or not.
So, as I mentioned, most stuff
is public on YouTube,
but videos
can either be marked private.
They may have been taken down
for some reason,
or they may have failed
processing
or may still be in the--
in the processing stage.
So, if a user
is not logged in,
they're only gonna see the
videos that are live and public
when they look
at somebody's uploads feed.
If you've logged the user in,
which we'll talk about shortly,
then they'll see all
of their videos.
So they'll see videos
that failed processing.
They'll see the video
they just uploaded
that hasn't been
processed yet,
and they'll be able to see
their private videos.
[clears throat]
So...
we'll go back to my--my not
so pretty developer site here.
So say I want to look at
the videos that I've uploaded.
So I can say,
"List my uploads."
And again, one of the things
that I want to illustrate
is since all the data types
are basically the same,
it lets you reuse your UI
for displaying them,
'cause I can just have
a default,
"Display a video feed UI,"
and so I've reused that
within here.
And so, whether I'm listing
my uploads or my favorites,
the only real difference
is, you know,
what--which service call
did I make
when I told it which feed
I wanted to retrieve.
[clears throat]
So if we were to look
at the code,
again, this--this is getting
pretty simple.
You know, basically, you know,
one line, two lines--
you can see
there's not much difference
between fetching
a user's favorites
or fetching
a user's uploads.
One of the things I want to kind
of insert a brief note about
is we offer a couple different
projections within the API.
These projections allow you
to give us some information
about what content
you're interested in,
as well as what you're expecting
to do with the content.
So right now we have
three different APIs--
or sorry,
three different projections.
the first one,
and is probably the most common,
is our API projection.
And this basically gives you
all the data
that we have available
for the content.
Typically, it uses plain text
instead of HTML,
so it's a little more compact
and a little bit easier
for you to parse out, like,
the description, for example.
Our base projection
is a little more relevant
if you're trying to build
something like a feed reader.
Like, you can take
any of our APIs,
you know, load it up in
a feed reader, and that will--
it is a standard feed.
It will parse and display.
And those responses
have HTML content in them,
so it's
a little more appropriate
if you're gonna just take it
and not parse out
the response itself.
And then finally,
we have a mobile projection
that is targeted
for mobile devices.
So, if you're building something
that's gonna run on mobile,
these are a little bit smaller,
a little more compact
to--to serve faster
over slow connections.
And then the streaming URLs
for the mobile formats
are there,
and they're optimized for use
by mobile devices.
[clears throat]
So I've mentioned a couple times
about authentication.
And so the first question
you may ask is,
"Well, it's gonna be
a little bit of extra work.
Why do I actually
need users to log in?"
So the two main reasons--
if you want to get access
to any private information,
the user's
gonna have to log in.
So, if they want to be able
to see their private videos
or their private playlists,
they'll have to log in.
But also, if they want
to see their inbox,
videos that people
have shared with them,
or if they want to be able
to manage their content
as it's being processed,
again, you have to be logged in
to do that.
But also, it's required
for all write operations.
So anything you want to do
that's gonna modify data,
you have to have a user,
and they have to be logged in.
We have two different mechanisms
for log-in.
How many people here
are primarily interested
in building web applications?
Okay. How many people
are building PC applications
or consumer-electronics
devices?
So a little bit smaller.
So most of you are doing
web applications.
AuthSub is--is what you'll use
for a web application.
The way this works
is that users will actually go,
and they'll log in
on a Google-hosted web page,
and then we'll redirect them
back to your site
with a token you can use
to operate on their behalf.
The nice thing
about this is that,
since the user sees that they're
logging in on a Google web page,
they don't have any concerns
about giving credentials out,
because they know
that they're giving
their credentials to Google.
It--yes.
man: Is there any plan
to support OAuth?
Harding: The question is,
"Is there any plan
to support OAuth?"
Most of the Google Data APIs
already do.
The challenge that we have
with the YouTube API
is that we have
different account types.
People can log in
with a Google account,
or they can log in
with a YouTube account.
And so we do plan to support it,
but it's taken us
a little bit longer,
'cause we have to support it
across both account types.
That's a g--
excellent question.
The other form of log-in
that we support right now
is ClientLogin,
and so this is for scenarios
where you don't have
a web browser
that can be directed
to our Google log-in page.
So, in this case, the user
will enter their credentials
directly into your application.
You'll make a log-in request.
And again, you get back a token
that you can use
to act as that user,
but the key here is that
the token you get back
is a temporary token,
and so this
will expire periodically
and, in some cases,
unpredictably.
And the reason is that we--we
don't have the ability
to manage those tokens
with ClientLogin.
With AuthSub,
the user can go
and, after the fact,
revoke access,
which is something
you need to be prepared for.
But it gives--again,
it gives the user confidence
that their credentials
only go to Google,
and they can manage
the applications access
after the fact.
Since they can't do that
with ClientLogin,
those tokens are temporary.
[clears throat]
So, with AuthSub, because
the browser's bouncing around
and you've got
some server-to-server calls,
you've got some client-to-us
and redirect,
I want to kind of step through
step-by-step how it works.
How many of you are familiar
with AuthSub or--or OAuth,
which works
quite similarly?
Okay, a couple people.
So this--this will be fairly new
to most of you.
The way you start out
with AuthSub
is you'll send
the user's browser
to a Google log-in page
to request access.
And so what
you'll need to pass us
is what URL should we redirect
them back to when we're done,
what is the scope of APIs
that you're interested in.
For YouTube,
that's gdata.youtube.com.
And then two parameters,
depending on how you're gonna be
using the AuthSub token.
So session tells us
whether or not
you're gonna do
a one-time request.
If you only have
a single API call to make,
you can just do
a regular token.
But you're probably gonna want
to have multiple API calls,
in which case you need to get
a session token
that will be permanent.
The secure parameter
allows you to actually register
your application with Google
and sign all of your requests,
which will be more secure.
It's harder for people
to snoo--snoop that token
and abuse it.
And when you do
a secure AuthSub
and you've registered
your app with Google,
we prevent--present a UI
to the user
that makes it clear
that this is more secure.
So you can start out--
you don't have to register.
You don't have to sign
to get this working,
but we encourage you
to do so,
because it's more secure
for the--for the end user.
Once that, uh...
once that initial UI comes up,
the user will log in.
They'll get the question of,
"Do you want to allow your--
your web app access?
And once they say, "Yes," we'll
redirect them back to your site,
and we'll put a token parameter
in the URL that we send them to.
Now, whether or not you're doing
a permanent AuthSub token
or a one-time AuthSub token,
this one is only good
for one request.
So, if you're doing one-time,
you can just use that
with your next API call,
and you're done.
But if you want
a permanent-session token,
you want to send that
back to us and say,
"I want to turn this
into a session token,"
and we'll give you back
a permanent token
that you then would store.
So users--you can only have
a certain number
of AuthSub tokens per site,
and so it's important
that if you do generate
a permanent-session token,
you want to store that
in a secure way
associated with your user,
instead of requesting
a new one
every time they come
back to your site.
And what you do from then on
is you just pass
that authorization token to us
when you're making API requests.
So once you've logged
the user in,
you're now able to--
to perform write operations.
So obviously,
you can create new entries,
you can update data,
and you can also delete data.
And so it's important
to make sure
that whatever UI
you're presenting
is consistent with what
the user's expecting you to do.
You know, the user
has granted you permission
to act on their behalf,
so don't--
you know, be careful and--
and treat
their data sensitively.
As I said,
all these write operations
will require
a user-authorization token.
Um...
for the YouTube API,
specifically,
we actually ask you to register
your application with us
so that we can keep track of
what applications are out there,
what's popular,
what people are using,
but also be able to keep track
of something--
if something goes wrong,
or if there's a problem
with your application,
allow us to contact you and work
to resolve the situation.
So, if you go
to code.google.com,
we have a link there
to where you can register
your application.
So, once you've done that,
with every request that you do
that needs to form a write,
you'll send us the user's
authorization token,
as well as your dev key
and the--the client's identifier
we assign you.
So this is kind of showing you
the HTTP header view.
The--again,
the client libraries
make a lot of the managing
of that state much easier.
What's probably most common
for doing writes is posts.
People want to create
a new entry.
They want to upload a video.
They want to add a favorite.
They want to insert a video
into a--into a playlist.
So most of these cases,
you're gonna want to do a post
to create a new entry
and a feed.
And again, you can either
generate the URL
that you're posting to,
or in all
of our feed responses,
once you're logged in
and sending us a developer key,
we'll actually give you
those related links saying,
"If you want to create
a new entry in this playlist,
"post to this feed.
If you want to upload
a new video, post to this feed."
One thing I want to highlight
is we do have a couple feeds
that are write-only,
which is a little bit unusual
until you think about it.
When you're doing ratings,
we don't actually keep track
of every single rating
that every user has made
and expose that.
So, when you're rating,
that's a write-only feed.
Similarly, complaints--
when you flag a video as saying,
"I think this violates
YouTube's terms of service,"
or, "I think this
is inappropriate content,"
we allow you to write those
so that users can flag videos
from your site,
but we don't allow you
to read them back.
So an example, say I--
you know, this is what
the actual adding of a favorite
would look like on the wire.
And so you can see there's not
actually too much involved
in doing
these write operations.
One thing I want to stress--
or there's two things
I want to point out here.
The first is if you see
in that URL up there,
I'm posting to /user/default.
So, once the user's logged in,
there's no need
for you to tell us what user
you're acting on behalf of.
We can identify that
from the authorization token.
So you can use default, and that
just simplifies your code.
You don't have to substitute
the user name
in all of the API requests
that you make.
You can see I passed in the
developer key, the client ID,
and the authorization token,
like I was told.
And then the actual entry
that I'm adding
into the user's favorite feed.
One thing
I want to highlight,
if you're doing
the client libraries,
this is pretty--it's kind of
the default behavior,
but if you are working
with XML directly,
it's important that you maintain
all of the entries,
all of the tags that you
may have gotten in an entry
when you read and then
when you post it back to us.
So there may be a new tag
that you're not aware of
that we add to the API,
and you need to make sure
that unknown tags in the XML
you pass through
back to us.
If you're doing
the client libraries,
it's not really an issue.
So, again,
for those of you who prefer
a higher-level language
than XML--
again, I'm grabbing
my YouTube service
within the client library.
And now
I need to worry about--
is the user on my site
logged in or not?
So I would have that persistent
association between my user
and the AuthSub token
that they granted.
If they're not logged in, if
they haven't given me permission
to act on their account,
I'm gonna generate an AuthSub
link to send them to
so that they go through
and give permission,
and they'll send them
back to my site.
But assuming that I do have
the AuthSub token set up,
I'm gonna tell the YouTube
service my developer key,
my client ID,
and the user's AuthSub token.
And this video happens to be
our--our Google I/O talk
about the APIs.
So say I want to add that
to the user's favorite
every time they--
they load up my page.
Get that video ID.
I'm gonna fetch it.
And then
I'll immediately post that
back into the favorite's feed.
And this is where I was saying
you don't need to worry,
when you're using
the client library,
about maintaining data,
'cause you're gonna fetch
the entire entry for the video
and then post it back.
So the last thing
I want to talk about is upload.
There's quite a lot
involved with upload,
which is why it--
it got saved for last.
So we have--it's kind of like
how we have two models
for log-in,
depending on whether or not
there's a browser.
We have two models
for upload,
depending on whether or not
the user is using a web browser.
So, if you have an application
such as Spore,
where there
isn't a web browser running,
we have what we call
direct upload,
so the application
has the video already.
It's gonna upload it
straight to our APIs.
This also can be used
for web applications
if either you want to have
your own copy of the video,
or perhaps you have
a web application
that is generating
the video itself--
something like Animoto, which
generates a video slideshow.
They generate the video
on their server,
and so they'll send it
directly to us.
But we also offer
what we call "browser upload."
And this allows your web app
to control all the metadata
that's associated
with the video,
but the user will upload
the video directly to YouTube,
so you don't have to worry about
having servers that can handle,
you know, hundreds, thousands
of users uploading video to you
just so that you can turn around
and send it back to our servers.
When you're uploading
with the API,
we actually give you access
to an extra set of information.
So this
is that third category
on video entries
that I alluded to earlier.
We have what we call
"developer tags,"
and this allows you to specify
your own tags
that are associated
with the video
as the API developer.
And these are visible
only to you,
and they're pretty much
free-form text
that you could use
however you want.
So you can define
your own taxonomy
that allows you
to organize your uploads--
well, the uploa--
the uploads that happen
through your use of the API.
You can see
in this example here,
you know,
maybe I want to associate
the user account on my site
with these videos,
so I can keep track of that,
as well as maybe I have my own,
you know, labeling system
for these videos.
So I want to flag--
this was just a test upload.
So, if you're doing
a direct upload,
you'll, again, just do a regular
Atom Publishing Protocol post
to the user's upload feeds.
Since there's metadata
and a video,
this happens
to be a multi-part post.
So I'll post first
the--the XML entry
and then the binary data
as a second post of the file.
One thing to point out,
we used the--the slug header
just to specify
what the file name was.
Browser upload,
kind of like AuthSub,
is a little bit more complex,
because there's
three entities involved.
There's our servers,
your web-application server,
and the user's browser.
So I want to kind of step
through the flow step-by-step.
So the first phase is, you know,
however you're doing your UI,
you'll negotiate with the user
about what the metadata is.
So you can allow them to specify
the metadata themselves,
you can automatically generate
the metadata for them,
or you can have them
specify the metadata
and then
perhaps inject your own.
Like Hunter mentioned,
a lot of our API users--
they'll tag
into the description,
you know, the URL
of their Web site
where the application occurred.
And that way, if users discover
this video on youtube.com,
they can go back to your site
to see where it came from.
Either way, eventually
you've got the metadata
that you want to have
associated with this video.
And so you'll take
that metadata.
Maybe you'll add your own
developer tags
so that you can organize
these videos within your site.
You'll post all of that to us,
and we'll give you back
the URL that the upload
should go to,
as well as a secure token
that you can send to the user
that they'll pass to us
with the upload.
So this is how we make sure
that whatever metadata
you associate with the video
stays intact,
even though the user
will eventually upload it
back to us.
So you'll take that URL target,
and you'll take that token,
and you'll present
a standard web form
to your user
with the file upload,
and the user's gonna submit that
directly to our API servers.
And so the large file
only has to come to us.
Once we finish processing
that upload,
we'll send a redirect
back to the user,
where they'll go
back to your site,
and we'll, again, inject
some parameters
into that redirect URL to say
what the video ID was,
you know, what the status was,
whether
it was successful or not
so that you can then present
the right UI on your site.
So I kind of want
to walk through
how this actually works
in practice.
Let me switch over here.
So Hunter
mentioned earlier Dogbook,
which is a Facebook application
that allows people
to, you know, have
a social network for their dogs.
So say I want to upload a video
of my dogs.
I'm gonna go here.
I'm gonna say,
"My dog Deuce
at the beach."
And in this case,
I'm gonna say,
you know, "I want to upload
the video now."
So, in this case,
they're gonna say,
"Well, I need to operate
on behalf of this user,"
so this is what
the AuthSub flow looks like.
In this case, they haven't
registered themselves
as a secure application,
which is why you get
this red box saying
they haven't registered
themselves
as a secure application.
You can also see that,
in their case,
they're only doing
a one-time request.
I can't read,
but that should say in there
it's a one-time request.
Since they're just doing
a single upload,
they only need to make
one API call,
and they can do
that one-time request.
So I'm gonna say,
yeah, I want to allow them
access to my account.
And AuthSub will send
back to--to their site.
And now I just pick the video
I want to upload...
which...
let me pull this up.
So you can see I'm working
through the file picker,
and I'm gonna pick
a small video,
so this will hopefully upload
a little bit quicker.
And I'll say upload.
Now, if you look down
at the status bar--
I don't know how well
that shows--
you can see, they're uploading
this video directly to us.
So Dogbook is not involved.
They don't have to worry
about all the bandwidth costs
of video coming in and out
of their system.
And you can see
now we're waiting.
So the video has been sent.
The API servers
are now processing this,
and pretty shortly here,
we're getting redirected
back to Dogbook,
saying that the application--
or the upload was complete.
And if we scroll down--
Oh.
[laughs]
You can see
this is the new video.
This is one
I uploaded earlier.
When a video gets uploaded,
it takes a little while
to be processed,
so there
isn't a thumbnail yet,
but since I was logged in,
Dogbook can see there
is this video that's there.
So they can see the video
still in progress.
If I were to flip over to--
to the list
of my videos here
and refresh,
you'll see this new
Dogbook video got added.
And you can see that they
injected "Dogbook movie"
into the title
so that they can maintain
some of their branding
with the video.
So we'll come back in a moment,
and I'll show you
that that actually did upload
and process successfully.
We'll give it
a minute to go.
man: Is there any mechanism
for checking the status
of the upload?
Say if it's a 20-meg upload,
it might take a while
to show action.
Harding: So the question was,
"Is there a way of checking
on the status of an upload?"
When you're doing the--
the browser form post,
since the browser actually has
to navigate the page to do it,
there's no way within the page
to see the status.
One of the things
that we're investigating is
how can we make it easier
to do the same mechanism,
but within something
like Flash,
that does allow you to monitor
a file post as it's going on.
So I kind of
want to walk through--
like, look at what's
actually going on the wire
in order for all that flow
to go through.
So I'm kind of skipping ahead
to step three.
We've already got
the metadata,
and they're gonna post to a-a--
one of our APIs to say,
"Get me an upload token
that I can hand to the user
to perform the upload."
So they'll pass in, you know,
the standard entry data,
the metadata,
the description,
as well as perhaps
some developer tags
to say
what user ID this was.
And our response
is gonna tell them,
"Okay, here's the URL
that that upload should go to."
And here's that encrypted token
I was referring to
that allows us to--to securely
trust the metadata
as it comes back
from the user.
I can then just display this
as a standard web form.
The--the next URL
is the URL on my site
I want the user to come back to
when the upload is done.
The action--
Oops.
The action up here--
ooh--is the--
is that URL that came back
in the token response.
And then I can inject
a hidden input with that token.
And then once the user's done
with the submission,
it'll come back to my site,
and you can see we'll give them
what the--the video ID was,
as well as what the status
of the video was.
So 200 means successful.
man: That's not a standard
form attributes--
the next URL.
Harding: The...
Oh, actually, yeah, this--
this is part of the action.
This isn't a form attribute.
So the--the target
of the post--
man: Oh, I see.
Harding: Yeah,
I had to break it
over a couple
different lines.
Yeah, sorry, it was just
a formatting--
That's the problem
with trying to put--
putting code in PowerPoint
never works that well.
All right.
So one of the things
you mentioned is--
you asked about checking
the status of the video
as it's being uploaded,
but it's important to check
for the status of the video
after it's uploaded as well.
As I mentioned,
it takes us a little while
to process the video,
get thumbnails generated,
transcode the video.
And since this video
isn't public,
because it's not live,
only the user
that's logged in
can see videos
that are still being processed.
Since we gave you the video ID
of the video
when the upload completed,
you can actually do a request
for just that one specific video
and check
on the status of it.
So if the video
is not actually live,
you're gonna see
this Atom draft tag,
saying this is still a draft.
And then we give you detail
about what's actually going on
with the video.
So it might be processing.
It could be rejected.
For example, if it was
a duplicate upload,
those will get rejected.
Or it may have failed processing
for some reason.
In a lot of cases,
the videos that fail
aren't actually video files
that get uploaded.
The other thing I want to stress
is, you know, you may do this
when you're checking on the
results of a video you uploaded,
but if you're showing the full
list of a user's uploads,
it's also a good idea
to look for these draft tags
so that you can differentiate
in your--your UI
videos that are live
versus videos that are not.
Yes, in back.
[man speaking indistinctly]
The question is if there's a way
to set up a-a callback
for when the upload
is complete.
Not right now,
but that's something
that we've been looking into,
just, in general,
having a notification system
for when things change.
Okay.
So say
I've uploaded a video.
I've checked to make sure
that it's live.
And maybe I uploaded some of
those associated developer tags
with it when I uploaded it.
The way that you search,
because these are just
a standard category,
is you use the standard
Google Data category syntax
for searching
within a category of videos.
In this case, I say, "I want
to use the developer tag Schema,
"and show me videos
that have
that string associated
with them."
And this way, I can say, "Show
me the videos that John uploaded
through my API."
One of the things I want
to point out--might be obvious,
but since the developer keys--
or the developer tags
are only available to you,
the API developer,
you have to use your developer
key when you make this request,
so we know who you are
and what developer tag
to look for.
So let's go back and see
if my video's done
being processed.
So you can see here,
you know, on the YouTube UI,
we differentiate.
You can see that the thumbnail
isn't yet generated.
So it looks like we're taking
a little bit of time to--
to get this video processed.
So we'll come back and check
on it again in a moment.
man: Is there a limit
to the number of videos
that an account can host?
Harding: The question is,
"Is there a limit
to the number of videos
an account can host?"
The answer is yes.
Right now if you're uploading
videos through the API,
we have a limit
of 2,000 videos.
The reason we do this
is YouTube
is about users sharing their
video and--with the community,
and so we do this
to make sure
that, you know, videos are being
uploaded to a user's account,
rather than having one account
for an entire site
and all the videos being
uploaded to a single account.
man: So, in the case here
with the dogs,
people are expected to--
to pretty much upload
to their own YouTube accounts,
as opposed
to that one centralized place.
Correct, yeah.
Yeah, so, like, in--in Dogbook,
you know, I-I go and it--
I grant it access
to upload the video
to my personal YouTube account
and so--
That's why we have
the developer tags
so that you,
the developer, can say,
"Show me, you know,
all the videos that I uploaded
as a--as a Web site,"
but while keeping the videos
in the user account
so that the user
owns those videos.
And so it--it kind of lets
both people manage that state.
man: Is it possible
to automatically register them
on the fly through the API
so that, you know,
it's kind of a seamless process?
Harding: Right, so the question
is can you register users
on the fly through the API?
Not at the moment.
Again, that's something
that we're looking into,
kind of the way--
You know, the way
that we're looking at this
is when you make
that AuthSub request,
you know, if you're not logged
in, you'll get a log-in UI
to say,
"Log in with your account."
What we want to do
is make it
so you can actually create
an account at that time
if you don't have one
and then authorize
at the same time
and then go
back to your site.
So it's not possible now,
but that's something
that we're working on.
So I want to show you
an example.
We don't have a good third-party
site that's doing these--
using
these developer tags,
but I want to kind of illustrate
how this can be done.
So one feature I can do
with these developer tags
is say, "Just show me
every video that's been uploaded
through my--
with my developer key."
So, in this case,
this is just a demo site.
I only have a couple videos.
So this is all the videos
that have been uploaded
through this site.
I can honestly say--
you know, say I want to do
a search.
Maybe I say, "Test," right?
So this will show me
all the test videos on YouTube.
But I want to do this
just focusing on my site,
so I'll say, "Restrict to that--
my developer tag category."
And you'll see
I'll only get the results
that were uploaded
through my site.
Or I can even go one step
further and say, you know,
"What are the videos
that this--
"my--my user, John,
on my site,
uploaded through my API?"
You can see that, in this case,
there's only one video
that I uploaded
with this account
through this site.
Let's go back, while we're here,
and check on--
on my Dogbook video.
And it looks like we're just--
we're a little slow today.
[laughs]
So, unfortunately, this video
is still being processed,
but if we come back later,
I'll prove that it--
it really did work.
And so, with that, actually,
I just want to point you
at a couple references.
code.google.com
is sort of the home
for all of Google Data APIs,
and our YouTube API
documentation is on there,
and we also have
a Google group
that's staffed by our wonderful
developer-operations team
and trying to make sure
that everybody plays nicely
and--and gets
their questions answered.
Then with that,
I want to open up
if there
are further questions.
Yes, in back.
man: Question
on the search API.
I saw that the max results
is 15 per page.
Is there a cap, like,
how many results you can get?
Harding: Yeah, the question is,
"Is there a cap
on the total number of results
that you can retrieve?"
The answer is yes.
The most you can get to
is 1,000.
Yes.
man: Could you put
the references back up?
Harding: Yeah, sorry.
[laughs]
man: Thank you.
Harding: All right,
if there's nothing else,
then it's actually time
for the lunch break.
So all of our staff--
or lunch is going to be served
out on the--the back patio.
We've got a barbecue set up
for you.
The staff will be out there.
So, if you've got questions
and you want to ask somebody,
find people in the--the gray
"Powered by YouTube" shirt,
and then we're gonna be
back here at 1:00
to resume the sessions.
Thank you.